je m'appelle john tu m'appelles
je peux
[Musique]
ban
autant pour moi j'ai envoyé un tweet le
monde lui été ménagé pour qu'on puisse
avoir une vraie dit cool j'ai pas le
courage de le virer c'est mon meilleur
ami
au laurie vous rentrez super tôt c'est
quoi tout ça pardon je manque à tous mes
devoirs
laurie je te présente angélique even li
fé foutu des ménages t'en fais pas je
vais t'aider à trouver un job promis
j'ai l'air débile nom de l'as tu es
genre de truc qu'on file au monde quand
on leur dit mamie est partie au cnr
paris si je regarde pas sous la
serviette pour mater ton petit hérisson
j'ai rencontré une fille super etc
[Musique]
ok voilà où commence la zone interdite